c'est l'une des plus grandes victoires
des écologistes est un des symboles de
la vague verte des municipales dans les
grandes villes
le 28 juin grégory d'où ces candidats
europe ecologie les verts devient maire
de lyon a choisi l'écologie alors lyon
défaite de cette étoffe dont sont ici
c'est même un doublé car bruno bernard
s'impose à la tête de la métropole de
lyon les écologistes mettent ainsi fin
au règne de gérard collomb l'ancien
socialiste passé à la république en
marche a pourtant tout tenté jusqu'à
s'allier à la droite locale pour
empêcher la prise de pouvoir écologistes
nous devons nous réunir
parce que nous vivons des temps
extraordinaires dans cet accord l air en
marche
le républicain françois noël buffet
devient candidat commun la métropole
tandis qu etienne blanc candidats aient
l'air à la ville de lyon laisse sa place
au dauphin de gérard collomb ce qui
n'empêche pas leur défaite
à peine ce séisme digérer une autre
campagne s'engage dans le rhône les
sénatoriales de septembre 2000
à mots clés
[Musique]
dont la foulée des municipales
victorieuse de juin les écologistes ont
désigné thomas d'hossus 38 ans comme
tête de liste aux élections sénatoriales
donc moi j'arrive à lyon il ya 25 ans 95
j'étais déjà militant écolo puisque je
manifestais contre les essais nucléaires
de jacques chirac a mûri en moi mais
j'avais 13 ans et puis petit à petit bon
ben voila j'ai appris j'ai appris des
choses et et en 2007 je me rapproche des
verts après l'échec de voynet à la
présidentielle je comprends pas pourquoi
le fait moins de 2% alors que les
questions qu'elles portent elles sont
cruciales pour notre avenir et donc je
me rapproche des verts à ce moment là et
je commence à m'engager auprès d'eux les
aider sur des campagnes et à militer
quoi après 2008 après les campagnes
municipales il ya 2009 et les succès aux
européennes
et puis 2010 fait à partir de ce moment
là où je m'engage plus fortement avec
les écologistes puisque je vais
travailler avec les élus à la région
dont plusieurs ont des trajectoires
intéressantes comme erik cole qui
devient maire de grenoble
mais sa plus grande victoire c'est celle
des municipales à lyon dans laquelle il
s'est engagé très tôt
certains le présentant même comme l'un
des artisans de l'ombre de ce succès
désormais il veut prolonger cette vague
verte en personne
voilà il reste encore des affiches et
des tracts des municipales de toutes les
campagnes qu'ont amené là où il ya
encore deux mois on était encore en
plein dedans moi je fais partie de ces
écolos qui pensent que l'écologie doit
rentrer dans les institutions
donc j'ai toujours défendu sa et compris
quand j'étais en lien avec des
associatifs qui sont beaucoup plus
militants et qui ont toujours une
défiance voire même une lente agonie
un antagonisme avec le pouvoir moi je
suis j'ai toujours voulu
qui est un débouché politique à toutes
ces luttes écolo et donc pour moi c'est
la suite logique c'est de s'engager et
d'aller au bout et j'ai d'ailleurs moi
mon rôle sur la campagne s'était aussi
d'amener des des associatifs et des gens
plutôt militants à prendre leurs
responsabilités et à devenir élus à
prendre les manettes
dans la foulée de la prise de la ville
et de la métropole de lyon le lvc
rapprocher des autres forces de gauche
l'élection sénatoriale se déroulant en
un seul tour
il faut éviter les divisions dans le
rhône socialistes mais aussi communiste
génération prg se sont ralliés aux
écologistes et présentent leur réunion
début septembre à la presse et puis les
élections sénatoriales sont le reflet de
cette dynamique électorale donc
naturellement nous avons travaillé à
continuer cette dynamique de
rassemblement ici dans le rhône pour
construire l'union qui face à la droite
qui présente une face divisés nous
voulons présenter un rassemblement qui
permet de créer l'espoir de l'alternance
tout prendre non prendre les 7 gilbert
luc devinaz ce sénateur socialiste
sortant accepte de se mettre en
troisième position sur cette liste
derrière deux écologistes en espérant
faire grandir les rangs de la gauche qui
ne comptait jusque là que deux sièges
sur les sept sénateurs du rhône et la
gauche et les écologistes sur
département ont pris le pari en faisant
une liste d'union d'être en première
division et après il reste à savoir
combien il y aura de liste en deuxième
division passe ici je prends cette image
c'est parce que jusqu'à présent on
pensait que les élèves seraient
totalement en première division mais
chine a compris ils ont décidé un peu de
se diviser
on a travaillé cet été avec les forces
de gauche qui ont constitué des
rassemblements ici aux municipales où
alex métropolitaine avec nous avec tous
les écologistes
on va travailler cet été pour arriver à
ce rassemblement ça n'a pas pu se faire
au niveau national donc on a pris notre
bâton de pèlerin ici localement on était
rencontrer chacune des forces de gauche
et écologistes ici à lyon et dans le
nouveau rhône et puis nous allons
constituer une liste de large
rassemblement pour cette élection
sénatoriale
actuellement il ya deux sénateurs de
gauche qui sont sortants et puis on
espère en avoir un troisième maintenant
avec ces dynamique qui s'est créée
depuis les dernières élections
face à cette liste de gauche unie et
rajeuni
françois noël buffet joue lui la carte
de l'expérience et l'ue depuis 2004 au
palais du luxembourg
c'est déjà la troisième campagne
sénatoriale pour le candidat les
républiques c'est une campagne
électorale on a l'habitude mais on
démarre tôt on finit tard et en même
temps on voit du monde c'est ça
l'objectif
mais c'est très plaisant elle en plus de
le fait de circuler dans le département
c'est toujours un moment agréable parce
qu on re découvre des endroits on
découvre toujours quel bout de quelques
nouveaux alors les rendez vous souvent
en tête à tête sans chaînes
car les électeurs des sénatoriales ce
sont majoritairement les élus des
conseils municipaux
ce jour-là à champagne-au-mont-d'or aux
abords de lyon
c'est avec une mère tout juste élu en
juin qu'il a rendez vous moi je vous
remercie de m'accueillir je suis pas
très loin n'est pas très loin pas la
première fois que j'ai un vrai champagne
nous sommes les élus des élus vous sert
d'intermédiaire des fois pour voir des
portes débloquer une situation à la
préfecture j'ai été le cas cette semaine
pour un nos collègues du département
intervenez auprès des administrations
prendre un contact avec un ministre ou
son cabinet parce que il ya un projet
qui vous intéressent qui est bloqué il
ya besoin d'un petit coup de pouce
donc c'est notre travail ça consultatif
des députés a pas du tout non dans la
nous votons les textes on vote on
éloigne les modifiant et ce n'est en
place après le système de la navette
entre l'assemblée et le sénat mais un
texte ne peut être promulguée qu'à la
condition qu'il soit voté en termes
identiques par les deux chambres
c'est l'acteur
2 et déjà qu'ils soient au fait de notre
occupation
donc il ya un lien qui se crée parce que
c'est vrai pour moi genre en tant que
simple citoyenne un sénateur jeunes et
les mois déjà de deux rencontres et
c'est important de les charger et puis
après j'attends un soutien donc il sera
vols quotidiens et cinématique se pose
particulièrement sur un sujet sur les
périodes en difficulté de j'attends un
soutien un conseil effectivement d'être
en porte d'entrée aussi pour relier nos
soucis auprès de ministères de la
préfecture je suis à chaque fois de
moins en moins étonnés de moins en moins
surpris de voir que dans les réunions
que nous faisons la moitié de
l'auditoire souvent la moitié de
l'auditoire a été élu pour la première
fois il a donc jamais voter pour les
élections sénatoriales et kylie a besoin
de faire de la pédagogie sur
l'institution et le rôle de
l'institution
ça c'est une c'était moi le cas en 2014
là c'est vraiment très très visite très
prégnant très réel
thomas do chu lui n'a pas forcément la
même connaissance des élus du rhône
ces grands électeurs des élections
sénatoriales pour combler son manque
d'expérience c'est donc en équipe qu'ils
mènent campagne loin de la métropole de
lyon où les vers ont emporté les
élections ils tentent d'aller chercher
des voix dans la partie plus rurales du
département s'en attriste le sénateur
sortant gilbert luc devinaz connaît bien
le territoire il a parcouru la france
demande à tout le territoire et la
rencontre est beaucoup beaucoup de mer
donc ça ça aide aussi à y apporter une
expérience et un regard plus voilà deux
sénateurs sortants c'est important pour
les pour les mères aussi d'avoir ce
ce regard là quand on a peut-être
l'intention de faire un peu peur est en
fait pas du tout on est accueilli comme
n'importe qui et le porter candidat ce
mois ci dont celle ci plusieurs
campagnes pour des partenaires donc
voilà ça fait plaisir
le continuel berda ouais moi je me
présentais puis présenté la démarche de
notre liste moi je suis thomas dessus je
suis élu métropolitain conseil
métropolitain à lyon et conseiller
d'arrondissement dans le viième je suis
adjoint à la culture dans le septième et
nous quand on fait nos rencontres avec
les maires ou les grands électeurs
c'est vraiment pour écouter vos
problématiques et les faire remonter
et puis on se dit que c'est une première
rencontre que ce sera pas la dernière
qu'on se reverra après au cours du
mandat
c'est un engagement qu'on prend à chaque
fois deux pas voilà faire ça juste pour
la campagne puis de ce qui était bon ami
et de puisse revoir pendant six ans
l'objectif c'est vraiment de se revoir
fêtes de saint gilles une chance d'être
élus sur les deux collectivités
territoriales parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre
loin de ses bases lyonnaise thomas do
sul laisse volontiers la parole à ses
colistiers
ce jour là c'est le local de l'équipe
bernard chaverot qui joue les
facilitateurs réamorce les sujets
clients le monde agricole
effectivement
on dit
vous êtes vous êtes juste là pour mourir
à la métropole j'ai envie de dire
j'espère qu'on va la nourrir parce que
pour le moment il n'y a que 5 % des
aliments autour de l'urbain pas
simplement le monde du ray 1 plaine de
l'ain et c'est qui qui alimente et s'il
ya quelque chose à faire passer au
niveau de nouvelles majorités
métropolitaine c'est à dire faut
qu'on mette le paquet et effectivement
ça va bien pour tout le monde c'est bien
morose à grinder d'un attendait mais ça
va être bien aussi pour le lyonnais
on y voit des gens retour j'ai du mal à
me situer par rapport à toutes les idées
que les autres expriment parce qu'elles
sont relativement similaires mais raté
l'épisode dotation à faire sur le
fonctionnement ya le département qui a
investi que tu réellement sur des gros
événements ou le musée gallo romain
on a des très belles affiches qui
arrivent jusqu'à nous mais on n'a pas de
moyens d'y aller hormis en prenant notre
voiture personnes écoutées les grands
électeurs éloignés de la métropole une
nécessité pour remporter des sièges de
sénateurs
car depuis une loi de 2015 le
département du rhône est divisé entre
d'une part la métropole de lyon qui
regroupe 59 communes et deux tiers des
habitants et d'autre part le nouveau
rhône qui regroupe tout le reste de
l'ancien département
en revanche les élections sénatoriales
se font encore à l'échelle de l'ancien
département et les élus seront sénateur
du rhône
certains jouent de cette carte
territoriale comme bernard fialaire
candidat centriste issue du nord du
territoire dans le beaujolais
il se bat pour que la métropole de lyon
negras pas ces élections
la spécificité c'est que je suis la
seule tête de liste issue du département
toutes les autres têtes de liste sont de
la métropole moi je et je pense qu'il
faut aussi qu'on respecte le département
ça veut dire que par des mêmes nous si
on est deux élus
et bien de toute façon il y en aura
aussi un de la métropole cder que je
peux me retrouver le seul élu du
département la normale que ce
département qui représente un tiers de
l'ensemble soit aussi représentée
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui sont
têtes de liste de qui sont issus de la
métropole et qui l'ont dit un qui n'ont
pas suivi parce qu'ils estiment qu'il
fallait que la tête de liste soit
métropolitaine comme si nous on était
les ruraux chargé d'apporter des bois
mais de pas vendre aux responsabilités
issu du parti radical valoisien bernard
fialaire tente de réunir sur sa liste la
galaxie centriste est en marche
en l'absence de candidat de la majorité
présidentielle
ils espèrent attirer leurs grands
électeurs on est sans étiquette
on veut rassembler tous les gens qui
sont situées entre et l'air d'un côté
qui sont assez nombreux d'ailleurs pour
présenter et puis communistes verts et
une partie des socialistes sur la gauche
donc c'est ce grand rassemblement
on s'est très clairement où on se situe
certains sont engagés dans des
formations du centre d'autres noms du
cap
voilà on se situe mais on souhaite le
faire de façon plus pragmatique
son credo territoriale il le décline
lors de réunions thématiques comme ce
jour là avec des élus adjoints à la
culture
loin de la métropole de lyon bernard
fialaire évoque les problèmes du
quotidien comme le transport pour aller
au musée
c'est un moment c'est que personne ne
veut prendre en charge le transport
or la culture ça commence avec les
écoles et personne n'a trouvé solution
aujourd'hui pour pour dire oui on va
souffrir dans ce qui va financer
chacun se réfugie dans son propre budget
on n'a pas les moyens
si la solution les écoles peuvent
demander au département quand même il ya
les subventions pour les déplacements
mais il faut que ce soit la volonté de
l'école boudent ils ya combien de sa
dépendent de la de l'agglo de
villefranche l'agglo d'une franche par
exemple pourrait dire il ya combien de
classes sur toute l'agglo centaines
combien de 200 enfin voilà il ya de quoi
faire une visite par jour presque si on
amène toutes les classes de l'agglo de
villefranche on peut pas penser même un
département comme ce milieu qui est
autour d'une métropole communion sans
être en permanence ça va qu'elle y en a
ça peut pas être simplement qu'une
métropole qui produisent la richesse et
qui
rui seulement nous en nous en donnerai
c'est pas pas comme ça il faut faire un
vrai partenariat sa candidature bernard
fialaire l'a mûri depuis un moment et il
a abandonné tous ses mandats pour se
lancer dans la course au sénat
j'ai pas souhaité me représenter aux
élections municipales ni même à ma
communauté de communes parce que je
pense qu'il faut laisser la place au
bout d'un certain temps et de mère en
revanche c'est utiliser toute cette
expérience tout le vécu que j'ai eu
comme élu local pour aller porter cette
expérience au sénat et représenter
l'ensemble de mes collègues avec qui
j'ai vraiment du plaisir à travailler
sur ce département
mais les autres listes espère aussi
attirer les électeurs plus ruraux ce
jour-là a fleuri dans le beaujolais au
nord du département
françois noël buffet mis sur un renfort
de première classe
le président du sénat gérard larcher
rendez-vous à la cave coopérative en
pleine saison des vins rouges
ensuite on va saint priest alors on a
décidé qu'il fallait je vous avertis
qu'on partirait vers 15 heures
valls et françois noël buffet vient ici
séduire les élus du beaujolais
traditionnellement acquis à la droite et
au centre
mais face au président du sénat ce sont
surtout les divisions au sein de la
famille politique qui préoccupe ces
grands électeurs
expliquez-moi dans quelle raison dans
l'euro vous êtes un deux trois listes de
me pendre son venir est-ce que ça ça ne
pas pas avoir un effet négatif sur le
résultat
comme à lyon où on s'est fait avoir par
les verts de manière magistrale
est ce que un bon jour je vous allez
arriver à nous entendre
ici je soutiens ça veut pas dire que
jette l'anathème sur tous les autres
je pense qu'aujourd'hui après les
élections municipales
la famille du centre et de la droite
à près de 60% des collectivités qu'elles
tendent le problème c'est de transformer
au plan national par une capacité d
alternative car je ne me résous pas à
n'avoir pour choir que la république en
marche un rassemblement national et donc
ça c'est bien de voir si les
républicains ont officiellement investi
la liste de françois noël buffet un
dissident s'est lancé dans la course et
c'est étienne blanc ancien candidat à la
mairie de lui
le parti a investi 1 10 ans suivante la
lipsky travers etienne fait une demande
d'investiture il lors il l'obtient pas
en les villans race est patente
c'est passé par le moment tu es dans là
c'est pas le moment et donc moi je
considère y avait des jours chauds
panneaux qui sont une inscrit quatre
éléments
venez les proches de nous les parkas
rejet
et il fallait donc des dissidents et sa
volonté n'a pas disparu
ah merde j'ai été investi par le
mouvement auquel j'appartiens qui est
également celui d'un autre candidat et
que ces sept autres candidats qui a
décidé de mener une opération personnel
et il organise la dissidence je le
regrette profondément car elle nuit à
l'unité que nous avons toujours
construite sur le département du rhône
nous avons toujours depuis des années
était unie rassemblée et là il crée
cette division je le regrette
profondément
nous espérons faire élire au moins
autant de sénateurs que nous l'avions
fait en 2014 et la campagne se déroule
elle se déroule très bien
je n'ai pas d'explication ce sont les
décisions qui sont prises la famille à
laquelle j'appartiens a pris la décision
de soutenir françois noël buffet hausse
annuelle du feu hérité avec catherine
des folies co2 excellent sénateurs et il
avait de la mûre et michel forissier et
il était légitime que je viens de les
soutenir
voilà la droite malheureusement c est
assez constante depuis quelques temps
elle réussi à perdre des élections qui
sont qui sont imperdable comme on dit un
petit peu par par dérision et aux
sénatoriales j'ai peur que cette cette
atomisation fasse perdre des sièges à la
droite il y a 6 ans
françois noël buffet avait remporté
quatre des sept sièges en jeu dans le
rhône
mais cette année les divisions pourrait
gâcher la photo de famille
et là on peut se rapprocher
le dissident a l'air c'est lui etienne
blanc
il espérait devenir maire de lyon en
juin dernier il faisait même campagne
avec françois noël buffet qui visez la
métropole mais l'alliance d'entre deux
tours avec gérard collomb l'a contraint
à se désister
il a décidé de se lancer dans les
sénatoriales sans l'investiture de son
parti
non c'est pas une des six danses c'est
une liste complémentaire
elle va communier à quelques instants et
s'adressait à ses électeurs des nouveaux
rhône qui sont peu représentés ou pas
représentés sur la liste officielle en
tout cas pas en position éligible et
puis elle va apporter aussi une réponse
à ce traumatisme qu'ont subis les
républicains dans une alliance à lyon
entre la république en marche et les
républicains qui a posé quand même
beaucoup de problèmes
alors écoutez je suis peut-être une part
de l'équation oui effectivement moi je
me suis retient par fidélité pour ma
famille politique
ce que je sais en revanche c'est que
dans notre électorat de la droite dite
républicaine
il ya un traumatisme qui est un
traumatisme profond et la liste que je
conduis elle peut permettre à ses
électeurs de passer gayet sur d'autres
listes
[Musique]
27 septembre 2020 jour de vote à la
préfecture pour les 3710 grands
électeurs du rhône a appelés à désigner
leurs sénateurs
covin oblige les restrictions sont
draconiennes les grands électeurs
patiente jusqu'à une heure et demie
avant d'accéder aux bureaux de vote
anonyme ou presque dans cette file les
candidats n'ont plus qu'à attendre les
résultats
oui plutôt confiance à une campagne
positive pour nous on a rassemblé donc
maintenant me voilà c'est le jour j
l'élection pluvieuse élections heureuse
on va dire où en plus il ya du monde qui
va être pour une fois donc la queue à
des élections c est rare plaisir mais
écoutez dans un esprit de confiance et
on attend évidemment que la journée se
termine mais sain d'esprit confiance
d'abord comme toute élection est de
toute façon
on ne peut plus grand chose donc il faut
attendre donc on essaie de ne pas trop y
penser en réalité
17h30 fermeture des bureaux de vote et
début du dépouillement dans les salons
de la préfecture interdite d'accès aux
journalistes
près de trois heures d'attentes avant le
verdict joindre canton quant à lyon car
là aussi bien vous avez des résultats
quand il ya d'abord françois noël buffet
qui réalise deux sièges la liste
lr officiel la liste d'union de la
gauche menée par deux écologistes
eh bien elle remporte trois sièges avec
le siège également du sortant socialiste
et il ya également le siège du décide en
lr etienne blanc qui réalise un siège
est alors la surprise donc pour le
septième siège eh bien c'est la victoire
de bernard fialaire je suis élu je reste
le sol sénateur centriste
malgré les listes dissidentes je suis
membre du parti radical j'aimerais
siéger peut-être au groupe rdse en tout
cas je m'assurerai d'avoir la liberté de
vote comme je les dis à tous les les
électeurs des grands électeurs
j'ai rencontré pendant toute cette
campagne je veux garder ma liberté de
vote et genevard de compte à rendre qu'à
mes électeurs
grand vainqueur de l'élection la gauche
remporte trois sièges deux écologistes
iront au sénat accompagné de gilbert luc
devinaz sénateur socialiste sortant
prolongeant la vague verte dans le rhône
3 sièges pour le rassemblement de la
écologistes et de la gauche
c'est historique pour pour nous
d'envoyer 2 2 sénateurs sainte-anne
sénatrice écolo à paris
voilà c'est très très très satisfaisant
pour nous de faire prolonger cette vague
verte ici de lyon de la métropole et du
rhône jusqu'à paris les écologistes
arrive à rassembler la gauche
ils peuvent arriver devant la droite est
arrivé ici à arracher un siège à la
droite donc c'est une très bonne
nouvelle et ça annonce des bonnes choses
pour la suite
à droite en revanche c'est la douche
froide
la liste officielle ne remporte que deux
sièges et le dissident etienne blanc un
seul je crois qu'il va falloir parler
sérieusement je crois qu'il va falloir
tirer les choses au clair et que
effectivement une il ya un discours de
vérité
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça avoir
une forme de quasi machine à perdre des
sièges singulièrement ce soir nous
étions quatre en 2014
nous sommes deux pour notre liste alors
que nous avons on voit plus de voix avec
le candidat dissident plus de voix et et
nous perdons un siège c'est quand même
quelque chose d'incompréhensible nos
électeurs ne peuvent pas comprendre cela
et j'en raison d'ailleurs parce que nous
mêmes nous sommes très en colère dit
cela après cette bataille électorale
direction le sénat pour ces sept élus du
rhône et premiers pas dans l'hémicycle
lors de l'élection du président du sénat
gérard larcher
monsieur dessus gérard larcher ayant
obtenu la majorité absolue des suffrages
au premier tour de scrutin je le
proclame président du sénat le président
durant les six prochaines années ces
sénateurs seront chargés de représenter
leur territoire de voter les lois et de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement au
sein de la haute assemblée
[Musique]